okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p here
is a voicemail from someone who is not
talking about bernie versus biden of
bernie versus warren rather but she is
talking about bernie and warren take a
listen to this hello david pakman and my
name is Debra and I'm from Colorado we
watch your show and I just wanted to ask
you to do a show where you show that
Bernie and Elizabeth are the dream team
and that they both have a plan that is
very similar and that if Elizabeth lands
haha right okay I guess that that is
that in any case yes you're bringing up
something so listen Bernie and Warren
are not the same and I've made very very
clear that they come from different
political backgrounds on a lot of
domestic policy they end up in similar
places on foreign policy there are
definitely differences between Bernie
and Warren so they're not the same but I
have said before and I said at the top
of the show today we need to make sure
that the critiques that are taking place
within the Democratic primary are not
going to do damage in the general
election and I don't know ultimately who
the nominee will be and I don't know who
the nominee is going to select as their
running mate but I think the narrative
of we would be so much better off with
either Bernie or Warren is a much better
narrative than the increasingly vicious
attacks that I'm seeing from supporters
of different candidates against
supporters of other candidates and this
is better than infighting for sure
although it is much too early to be
talking about running mates we're trying
we haven't even had a single vote cast
so far in the actual Democratic primary
but I like your attitude that's for sure
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show